The local chain dynamics function is a super simple function to set up.
And this is more useful when you have a longer chain of bones compared to the jiggle function.
So back into our project here, if we search for local chain dynamics,
we'll find our function just here, I just zoom in on that.
You can see that all the function really needs as an input is an array of bones.
So this will essentially just be from your first to your last bone in your chain.
Now if I come up to the viewport here and show our bones,
we've not got many long chains of bones on this mesh here,
but we do have a chain of two bones here for these cables underneath the main gun.
And what we're going to do is select those two bones,
drag them in and choose create item array.
And for this, you would just connect them straight up to the bones input pin.
And if we connect the logic up, we should quite quickly see that we get some movement on these or this chain.
So it's super, super quick to set up.
And now you have the option to play with all of the properties of the function here.
So we have the strength and damping that we can tweak,
which works the same as it does with the jiggle function.
You also have access to the blend start and end here,
which essentially allow you to determine the strength of the dynamics at the start and end of the chain.
And then we have blend twist, which allows you to determine how much twist you want on the chain.
So what we could do here, if we see it moving perhaps a bit too much,
we could increase the strength here, which will increase the stiffness to something like six.
And now it feels a little less floaty and there's a little bit more rigidity to it when it's coming back to settle.
And you could crank that up to eight just to see how things look.
And you can see it doesn't swing out as far and it's a bit more stiff than it was before.
This chain's not super long, so we're not going to be able to get many settings out of the blend start and end and twist settings here.
But what we can do is add our other chain.
So we have two cords hanging underneath this gun.
So I could select all of these cords like this, connect them up, hit compile.
And that will affect both of the chains individually like that.
Now you could do this for several chains and they'd use the same settings essentially,
but if you wanted to change these, you'd need one function per chain.
To demonstrate this with a longer chain of bones, I've just opened up another character here
and I very quickly made just a pelvis control that we're copying the transforms from onto the pelvis bone.
And then the local chain dynamics function where we've set up an array that contains our spine and our neck.
So you can add a bunch of bones in here as long as they're in a chain
and then you can see that that affects the whole body in this case.
And this is how it essentially works just with a longer chain here.
And again, you can tweak all these settings to make anything a little bit stiffer.
So you can see that if this was kind of moving robotically, you might be able to get some chain movement
on any sort of hydronic pipes that you might have or chains that you might have.
And obviously you can tweak all these settings here to customize the look of that.
But yeah, I just wanted to briefly show that to show that it's not just for short chains of bones that we used it for in the demo here,
but you can also use it for long chains.
And really that's more what it's designed for in comparison to the jiggle function.
But there we go. That's just a quick setup of the local chain dynamics.